[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing the instrument through which
witches and wizards channel their magic
i am of course talking about ones more
specifically we're going to be
discussing ones in the context of their
necessity how come some wizards user
wants while others seemingly don't have
the need for one to tool and lastly and
more importantly why don't witches and
wizards use multiple ones
there's source information in the
original books which suggests that using
multiple ones is plausible so why isn't
anyone doing it let's dive in now we
know that in the wizarding world it is
commonplace for young witches and
wizards to visit ollivanders and receive
their first wand an instrument with
which they are able to begin honing and
channeling their magical abilities a
wand is the object through which a witch
or wizard channels his or her magic it
is made from wood and has a magical
substance at its core
ones made by ollivander have caused a
phoenix feather unicorn hair or dragon
heart string and are of varying woods
lengths and flexibilities and on the day
that they get their first extremely
personal wand their journey into the
depths of the whistling world truly
begins finally able to untap and uncover
its mysteries the importance of one
donorship in harry potter is emphasized
to suggest that essentially no witch or
wizard no matter how powerful or weak is
complete without their wand the wand
chooses the wizard that much has always
been clear to those of us who have
studied one's law if you are any wizard
at all you will be able to channel your
magic through almost any instrument the
best results however must always come
where there is the strongest affinity
between wizard and wand these
connections are complex an initial
attraction and then a mutual quest for
experience the one to learning from the
wizard the wizard from the wand and from
the day the pairing of wand in which
wizard first occurs the wand becomes
more and more a vital part of their
existence the wand and want owner
establish an almost symbiotic
relationship and part of this aspect
comes down to the fact that ones are
quasi-sentient able to independently
perform actions through their own will
okay so ones are important and the
relationship with their caster is
important but the first thing i want to
look at here before we get to multiple
ones is are they necessary we see some
wonderless magic in harry potter and
it's always a bit confusing wait a
second don't you need a one to perform
that spell well here's the thing
wonderless magic only really stands out
to us because of its ubiquity among the
wizarding world that we have become
familiarized with through the books and
films we are indoctrinated from the
start to think that a wand is essential
to magical achievement where in reality
oneless magic is actually a norm for
other species and cultures perfect
examples of magical beings that are able
to perform magic without ones include
goblins and elves whose lack of wand
usage has even prompted them to refer to
humans as wand-bearers
expanding on this in the world of harry
potter the wand is said to be a european
invention which means that cultures
outside of europe would have always
practiced magic without one it is said
that native american wizards have their
own methods of producing magic predating
colonization and that african wizards
only adopted the wand in the 20th
century so really oneless magic is a lot
more common than you may think i think
that outside of these cultures and
species the use of oneness magic in a
world where the use of a wand is
ubiquitous can be attributed to one of
two things powerful magical ability vast
experience and calculated casting or
lack of experience and accidental
casting essentially if you're a gifted
witch or wizard and you're powerful
enough to channel magic without a wand
you don't need it however for those that
have more difficulty channeling magic or
want to cast an exceptionally powerful
spell then a wand might be a good way of
achieving this
for the most part i imagine wizards like
dumbledore and voldemort don't see the
need for using a wand as their power has
transcended most others in the wizarding
world however come time to duel a wand
might be a lot more important and that's
likely why voldemort and dumbledore
heavily leveraged their ones against one
another in their fated jewel okay now on
to multiple ones so if ones aren't even
necessary to begin with why on earth
would one entertain the idea of using
several at a time does it allow you to
channel magic further why does harrah
use three ones against fenrir greyback
in the deathly hallows
he leapt over an armchair and wrestled
the three ones from draco's grip pointed
them at grey back and yelled stupefy the
werewolf was lifted off his feet by the
triple spell flew up to the ceiling what
it sounds like from the above passage is
that harry using several ones actually
amplified the effects of the spell
causing greyback to fly up to the
ceiling so is that truly the result of
several ones or would one wand have done
the trick
here's what i think harry's spell in
this instance was not amplified by using
multiple ones
okay but if it didn't amplify the
effects then why did he use them the
answer reflex if we examine the passage
closely we can see that harry rather
aggressively wrestled the ones from
draco's grip immediately yelling a spell
this wasn't a controlled environment
harry didn't see three wands and think
oh that'll be triple the power he just
did whatever he could in the moment and
as it turned out draco had three ones in
his grips
okay now i'm going to dive into reasons
for how i think using multiple ones
could work in some extremely rare cases
but doesn't work most of the time the
first problem is wand ownership as i
mentioned earlier the relationship
between a wand and a witch or wizard is
highly unique and extremely complicated
it's a sort of symbiotic bond a
one-on-one relationship we know what
happens when witches and wizards are
paired with the wrong wand think ron
weasley's hand-me-down wand or neville
longbottom's wand it just doesn't end
well these illustrate that it's hot
enough to gain the allegiance of one
wand let alone multiple so how can we
reasonably expect that a given which or
wizard could garner the allegiance of
multiple and then capitalize on all of
them at once in a battle scenario yes
it's possible to gain the allegiance of
more ones by besting the previous owner
but it's also a highly complicated
subject and the laws of ones are not
entirely clear as we've seen with the
highly temperamental elder wand don't
get me wrong ones are capable of
changing masters but it's not so easy to
win someone's wand from them usually you
have to disarm stun or kill the opposing
witch or wizard and even then the ones
may not choose you it may honor its
connection with its previous master
furthermore i can't imagine it'd be easy
to wield multiple ones how do you even
hold three things in your hand at once
like that sounds hard to aim try holding
three chopsticks in one hand and aiming
them all the same thing it's not easy a
real world example would be weapons sure
a sword is a powerful weapon but using
two doesn't mean that it's going to be
an improvement over one it probably just
means you'll be less effective with each
and that's kind of how i see the use of
multiple ones going for someone even
with proper allegiances established with
all of these ones which is already
highly unlikely i think that the only
way that this could work is if someone
happened to have multiple ones choose
them while they were young this would
give them allegiance to multiple ones
and also give them an opportunity to get
used to multiple ones but even then i'm
not sure it would be any kind of an
advantage what do you guys think did you
ever think about this let me know in the
comments section below until next time
remember
time will not slow down when something
unpleasant lies ahead
[Music]
you